c'est non non tu es toi 4,2 soit le
tribunal quand on parle aux jeunes qui
fument et qui condamne les messieurs et
dames avec de bonnes innocent tout le
monde est coupable il peut le faire
ma moyenne s'en sortir vraiment
est flagrant
elie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'audience est reprise je vous rappelle
que nous jugeons aujourd'hui ici havane
alan stivell qui est inculpé d'atteinte
à la sûreté de l'état d'atteinte au
patrimoine national doutera jo lang et
d'exhibitionnisme puisqu'il montre son
biniou et tous les passants
la société française monsieur stivell
effectivement beaucoup de choses à vous
reprocher et
et tout cela va être maintenant exprimé
également par le représentant de cette
société français son porte parole
le procureur général de la république
des proches française nuit
[Applaudissements]
puis
françaises français beige beige vanity
case dernier ticket
mon massif central monsieur l'avocat le
plus badinter
monsieur super biniou mesdames et
messieurs les jurés public chéri mon
amour
[Musique]
bonjour ma colère salut ma hargne et mon
courroux coucou debout camarades seine
et marnaise et camarades seine et
marnais allons nous encore longtemps
plié l'échiné sous le joug français
je dis non il est temps il est grand
temps que la seine-et-marne retrouve son
authenticité spécifiques
[Musique]
c'est un spécificité autonomic son
autonomie cité authenticité et sa
seine-et-marne ici tude sans laquelle il
n'y a pas de seine-et-marne is it est
oui
[Musique]
debout les damnés de la terre secouez
vous seine et marnais lève toi fils de
melun lève toi à paire de couilles y
debout [ __ ] de mots ce qu'est vous
secouez moi
orange y net or c'est vrai ça vient de
la seine et marne seine et marnaise est
cerné marnais entendez-vous dans nos
campagnes mugir ces féroces parisien ils
viennent jusque dans nos bras égorger
nos betteraves fourragères
jeudi assez d'or les français nous vous
boutron or d'ozoir la ferrière
au dernier recensement la seine et marne
quant à huit cent vingt mille habitants
en comptant les femmes et les juifs
et c'est cette marée humaine de huit
cent vingt mille au privé qui se lèvent
aujourd'hui pour exiger du pouvoir
central de paris
la reconnaissance ici tude de
l'authenticité une particularité smic du
cinéma rice nisme et la formation à la
ferté sous jouarre d'un gouvernement
spéficiquement cerny marnick
[Applaudissements]
un gouvernement qui prenne en compte les
problèmes intrinsèquement intrinsèque de
notre pays dont nous chasserons s'il le
faut par la force
l'occupant étranger et notamment les
3000 bretons qui vivent à coulommiers
[Applaudissements]
parlons-en des bretons alan stivell est
un escroc
il est aussi breton que je suis
socialiste c'est vous dire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
braaten yens et bretagne 1 n'écoutez pas
ce barde site info j'ai ici l'acte de
naissance cette immonde gargouilles qui
mangent les crêpes des français cet
homme est un atroce bâtard de juifs
anglais et de gourdes italienne et quand
vous saurez mesdames et messieurs les
jurés
quand vous saurez ce qu'est vraiment un
anglais ce qui est vraiment une
italienne vous chasserez ce [ __ ] à
coude bindra gueule il ya deux sortes
d'italiens les italiens du nord qui
vivent au nord les italiens du sud qui
meurent au sud
les italiens sont tous des voleurs il
n'arrête de manger des nouilles que pour
voler et je sais de quoi je parle
il m'arrive souvent voyagé à travers
l'italie et bien je peux en témoigner
on ne m'a jamais rien volé n'est ce pas
extraordinaire
comme les espagnols les italiens ne
parle pas le français
vous n'allez pas le croire et pour se
comprendre entre eux et malheureuse
sentent obligés de parler italien c'est
horrible la capitale de l'italie
s'appelle rome en hommage à raimu et
rémoulade qui fondèrent la ville à
quatre pattes sous une louve mais enfin
passons
[Musique]
peu de villes offrent aux touristes
autant d'attrait que rome certaines
ruines romaines sont tellement belle
qu'on dirait le palais bourbon mais peu
de gens de nos jours savent où est née
la renaissance italienne et bien je suis
en mesure de vous le dire ici la
renaissance italienne est né en italie
michel ange le tintoret frangélik au
lunar de vinci saint raphaël sammartini
etc
tous étaient italiens plus encore qu'à
rome c'est à venise que le visiteur
s'esbaudit devant tant de splendeur
offertes aux regards
je ne parle pas seulement des filles qui
ont des nichons énorme mais des
innombrables palais somptueux qui borde
la lagune vénitienne ou la ville
s'enfonce désespérément de jour en jour
au rythme lent de sa propre décadence et
de la nôtre entraînante aux abysses
toute l'intelligence et la beauté du
vieux monde il faut être con aux
footballeurs pour parrainer venise en
quittant venise en quittant veut ni je
me suis dit léon c'est à venise que tu
reviendras à mourir oui depuis le 10 mai
quand je suis tout seul je m'appelle
leone en hommage à léon blum donc alain
stivell et comparé sa mère eunice ont
maintenant son papa le sinistre anglais
john fitzgerald ismaila stivell
l'anglais est appelé ainsi à cause de
ses traits anguleux
c'est pourquoi les anglais sont tous des
[ __ ]
tandis tandis que le français lui est un
onglet comme le cochon alors que le
cochon et le français sont omnivores
l'anglais manche du gigot à la menthe du
boeuf à la menthe du thé à la menthe
voire de là mentalement
non content de faire bouillir les
viandes rouges l'anglais fait cuire les
viandes blanches comme jeanne d'arc qui
mourut dans la seine maritime et dans
les flammes
en lançant vers dieu ce cri d'amour mon
dieu mon dieu baisse un peu le chauffage
les deux caractéristiques de l'anglais
sont l'humour et le gazon sans humour et
sans gazon l'anglais s'étiole et se
faner devient creux comme un concerto de
schoenberg
oui je pense notamment à ses quatuors à
cordes dont la tonalité fondée sur la
méthode sérielle nous brise les
boulettes année cnic l'anglais ton sans
gazon très court ce qui permet à son
humour de volée au ras des pâquerettes
comment reconnaître l'humour anglais de
l'humour français et bien l'humour
anglais souligne avec amertume et
désespoir l'absurdité du monde alors que
l'humour français se moquent de ma
belle-mère en dehors des heures d'amour
on peut reconnaître l'anglais à son
flegme cas ce que le flegme britannique
dans britannicus 1669 racines nous
montre comment son héros continue
imperturbablement de lire l'osservatore
romano pendant qu'est néron lui donne
des coups de pieds dans le phlegmon d'où
l'expression le flegme en britannicus
flegme britannique
exemple de flegme britannique
quand une bombe de 100 mille mégatonnes
tombe dans sa tasse de thé l'anglais
reste plongé dans son journal
edit ça se couvre deuxième exemple quand
l'anglais entre en érection
il reste dans sa femme et des ressources
élèves
les anglais ont-ils un chef
bien sûr imbéciles sinon ce serait des
bêtes le chien des anglais s'appelle la
dame de fer
de même que madame polystyrène expansé
ma dame de fer est inflexible
[Applaudissements]
elle ne bouge pas elle ne plie pas ne
cille pas même quand son mari la besogne
la dame de fer ne bouge pas nous sommes
là en présence d'un cas d'inflexibilité
tout à fait étonnant qui n'est pas sans
rappeler celui de mirabaud n'en sortant
que par la volonté du peuple où la force
des zigounette
l'anglais enfin est-il une créature de
dieu bien sûr nous sommes tous des
créatures de dieu
ligny lez qui va au ruisseau est une
créature de dieu la hyène et le chacun
là sont des créatures de dieu même
gaston defferre est une créature de dieu
sauf le yacht qui est des chantiers
bénéteau à saint gilles croix de vie en
vendée
donc alan stivell est coupable
[Musique]
merci monsieur le procureur général
lorsque nous aurons les amis du cinéma
je penserai à vous mais c'est non non
[Musique]